in this video i'm not only going to tell
you how much faster the iphone 12
5g is compared to the previous iphone's
4g lte
but i'll also compare the iphone 12's 4g
because
let's face it not everybody has 5g just
yet
and with that i have some incredible
results for you including some hot spot
tethering comparisons
i tested throughout the day and all over
town to give you a real world comparison
both in spots with great reception
and peak hours along with off hours and
also places
that used to be dead zones for me but
thanks to the iphone 12 they aren't
anymore with that said the 5g that i'm
going to show you guys is sub 6
5g because well that's the only one i
have here in my town
and chances are if you have 5g that's
what you have too
before we jump in it is very important
to note that both the iphone 12
and the 12 pro have identical antennas
where last year the non-pro had worse
reception
and that the modems are also the same
exact top-of-the-line snapdragon x55
so apple didn't cheap out on the 12 and
12 mini
compared to the pros i started out early
morning outside of my house before the
networks were being hit
and my 11 pro max managed one of the
best scores i've gotten there
36 megabit per second download and 25
upload
testing the iphone 12 manually set to
lte only
i got 39 megabit per second download and
32
upload so slightly better but not by
that much
switching over to the slowest but the
most common 5g
i got speeds of about 70 megabits per
second and an upload of 28.
that's about twice as fast compared to
the iphone 11s lte
but what does this mean in the real
world well web pages do load quicker and
i can actually stream 4k video with
these speeds
instead of having occasional buffering
even with 1080p video
on the iphone 11. i then headed to my
church which is the most frustrating
area in terms of cell reception
with my iphone 11 pro i only have
service in a few spots
and in one of those spots my speeds
showed 6 megabit per second download
and 0.37 megabit per second upload
this speed is frustrating i can't stream
any video
everything loads very slowly and i even
have issues sending not only photos
but even text and sometimes calls
popping the same sim
into my iphone 12 i went from six
megabit per second download to 38.8
and for the upload from an unusable 0.37
to a slow but usable 2.2 and this is
using the same exact
4g lte network not 5g switching 5g on
resulted in an even faster 48 download
and 4.3 upload that is 8 times faster
download speeds and 12 times
faster upload speeds and that means that
i'm going from a frustrating experience
to an actually decent one for everything
including streaming video
the next place i tested was at my office
which is a concrete building next to a
ton of other businesses that use the
same network
my iphone 11 pro got a slow download
speed of 20 megabit per second
and upload of 11 while the iphone 12's
4g lte
managed 32 download and 13 upload which
is noticeable but not a huge improvement
switching to 5g resulted in a much
faster 52 download and 23 upload
so more than twice as fast for upload
and download now before i move on to
another frustrating dead spot in my city
i want to pause for a second and share
another test here at the office
that might be very relevant to you
especially this time of year
when we first got in the iphone 12s we
had a major snowstorm and even though
the 5g had lower bars
it wasn't really affected by the snow
even though the iphone 11 was
getting 45 megabit per second download
where my 11 got an
unusable 2 megabit per second i then
retested both
using only lte and this time the 12
scored a faster but still fairly slow 4
megabit per second
compared to 22 megabit per second so how
in the world is this possible if the
iphone 12 was
actually showing lower bars well as i
mentioned at the start apple didn't
cheap out and it's using the very best
snapdragon x55 modem
which is what connects it to the towers
the older iphones have been using
intel modems which are much slower even
though it shows more bars of reception
in the afternoon i tested another
annoying dead spot on the way to my
house
where even podcasts will stop playing as
i drive by
i pulled over in the general area and my
11 pro got 10 megabit per second
the iphone 12 using lte got 12 so
that's not really that much better there
and then i switched to 5g
and that resulted in almost 18 download
so it's not twice as fast but it's
getting there now even though i was
expecting more here i do want to add
that i've been driving by this part of
town
at least twice a day for about two weeks
now and not once has my podcast
or streaming music buffered like it did
with the 11 which is really nice
for the next test i drove downtown in
the evening during peak hours
and my iphone 11 got a really fast 60
megabit per second with 6
upload whereas the 12 got 70 download
and a massive
55 upload this time switching on 5g
resulted in 114
download in 90 megabit per second upload
speeds i have to say that i am glad that
apple added 5g
to all of their new phones even the
iphone 12 mini because if they didn't go
for 5g
then they would still be using intel
modems and we wouldn't be seeing these
great speed improvements
and for the final test before talking
about tethering i tested
in the evening closer to a tower and my
iphone 11 got a very fast 85 megabit per
second download
and 50 for upload now this is the best
i've ever gotten on my iphone 11 pro max
in my town
and these kind of speeds i was really
thrilled with until i tested out the
iphone 12 that is
testing standard lte it was about the
same speed being
outside and close to the tower but
switching on
5g resulted in a crazy 205
megabit per second download and 81
upload
now keep in mind that this is the
slowest 5g out of the three different
kinds
if you have mid band 5g in your city you
would be getting 400 to 600 megabit per
second at this point
and with millimeter wave it would be
well over a thousand
now thankfully unlike many androids all
iphone 12 support
every single kind of 5g so once your
city adds it you will have full access
i also want to point out that some of
you guys already have faster lte speeds
in your cities
and some of you might have slower ones
it really depends on your carrier and
how many people are connected to that
tower
if your iphone 11 speeds are already
better than mine
it just means that if you buy an iphone
12 it will be even faster
based on my tests in many cases much
faster
even without 5g and now let's get to a
test that really shocked me
even more than the other ones and that
is tethering
now i often use wi-fi hotspots on my
phone to share data with my macbook
and unfortunately it's really slow
testing my iphone 11 in the evening i
got a painful
three megabit per second download and
less than one
upload meaning that streaming video is
only possible with really bad quality
and you can forget about uploading
switching to the iphone 12
i got 36 megabits per second download an
18 megabit per second upload
which is a massive difference and
similar to the speeds that many people
have with their regular wi-fi
with the speed you can stream and you
can even upload videos and in general
it's a pretty decent experience
overall i have been absolutely thrilled
with the cell reception of the iphone 12
not only with 5g but even just the
regular 4g lte
the max speeds are much faster and in
areas where i had little to no signal i
can now use my phone
like i normally would this alone makes
my iphone 12 a worthy
upgrade from any previous iphone but of
course there are much more differences
so if you guys want to see my full
comparison or the two weeks later review
you can click right over there let me
know your thoughts down in the comment
section below and if you enjoyed this
video why not subscribe by clicking that
circle above this been max and i will
see you
in the next video